le ringard que ce lancement j'ai pris
les six matches amicaux bal qui sera à
mes côtés dans un instant il héberge ya
de mcafee revient pas malin rappelle
reuters train joints dans torsen stress
que je suis étranger didot je suis très
étrange freeway d'abord au ccap coût est
bonne c'est ya l'humour arrivent de
l'ouest est bien calé à la toile est
bien là il sèche cheveux et tous les
âges pasto aimons tous me hla hla frères
tous merci beaucoup comme ça tu es un
gars inquiétudes diva il faut que y'a du
boulot quoi le matin tu te réveilles tu
sais comment faut que ce soit comme ça
alors moi tu peux faire tu peux juste
sur ton et faire pétrole hahn pensez-y
j'te jure appelle-moi camille pétrole
hahn
il faut le faire pour être commencer toi
badji mon bébé je suis pas venu là pour
toi et les vocal qui est arrivé tôt rien
du tout à part ça je suis à leurs
enfants anglais alors les 24 heures tv
bah ouais ça reste venir changer mon jeu
peut prendre le jus j'ai l'impression
que le courant passe
alors là
24 arte les 24 heures pour la journée et
tv pourquoi pas si c'est la télévision
non pour très vite au conte et quoi
ouais ça fait quatre mois qu'ils nous le
disent
ça fait 15 mois que le tout et c'est
parti on va regarder ce qu'on a vu alors
tenez matin nathalie rihouet galère un
petit peu et que les cartes 3d pour
faire sa météo tu sens qu'elle préférait
la période antenne 2 les températures
prévues pour cet après midi elles seront
donc mis au pas il ne marche pas mon but
si ça marche ah bah non mais ça va trop
vite olalala technique mais reviendront
chez l'être
00 00 et on connaît tous le fameux
regarde mes hanches ont quand même
beaucoup et bien sûr françois dauré
petite fille encore plus doué quand elle
est surprise
m
russe autour du jeu du genre mis ça
faisait longtemps qu jean-mi quand il
vous demande de dire camion boîte
jean vincent placé a été placé en garde
à vue cette nuit on a les images
explique de saada où quand il a
découvert le procès verbal de soldats
cassé ni bel air est alors les
marseillais w9 sont toujours en
australie font le tour des boîtes de
nuit sur le dancefloor ils ont croisé
une copine qui les a bluffés par son
niveau de danse
j'adore
[Applaudissements]
on verra leur elle mettra du match
c'était vous pas qu'il est en boîte de
nuit à nyon celle-ci ce week-end
et pourquoi serait pas à c'était vrai ou
c'est pas si elle ou pas elle et elle a
dit qu'elle était en boîte de nuit on a
envoyé une vidéo on sait pas si loin
mais on va la remettre
c'est normal à bien n'espérez sais pas
je vous donnerai c'est pas moi jennifer
réceptif quoi une grille est parti là
mais bon on va quand même parler de
grève chez obligé de trains ter énorme
pagaille dans tous les métros êtes
drôlement bt cyril l'échelle
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
eschena faut envoyer des journalistes de
partout et tous les rendez vous êtes une
vraie galère
hitchcock et changement à saint philippe
du roule et on ne sait pas j'ai la
chance je marque beaucoup je fais tous
mes travaux
c'est vrai que je suis toujours à côté
d'eux prendra même ligne la cèze non là
c'est trop de quoi il n'a trop paraître
à pied je marche seul ouais vous
comprenez qu'elle ligne toute la sainte
journée lors desquelles il a 11 lahonce
croyons d'orléans
s'il vous allez métro nous voilà donc
pas que la chance va je suis à côté je
vous dis la vérité je suis tombé moi et
toi tu as été embêté ce matin 5 heures
du matin à 5h du mat camille tu crois
que c'est comme toi là non c'est normal
que votre mère m'insulte par texto paru
sans tarder pour savoir manon way sur
ses vraies pages où j'allais marquer
belle-maman j'en ai pas de mine mais
c'est avec et c'est que cette gare car
bon sens mathieu merci de ne pas jurer
sur ma vie quand tu raconte des
conneries
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
amer de l'année c'est énorme
tout va bien c'est assez fort ça c'est
vrai
et merci calme alors qu'abby donc on
parlait des graves selon me prenez votre
mal est fait mais ils sont tombés sur un
chauffeur de taxi moto qui est hyper
heureux parce que lui baky à des grèves
baisse un peu plus donc lille est
content que tout soit bloqué forcément
il a d'abord laissé exploser sa joie à
18 heures derrière la journaliste qui
dort tranquille ou et deux heures après
il était de retour pour finir sa choré
[Musique]
[Rires]
et tout le monde était sur les nerfs
jean pierre elkabbach sur ces news
pourtant d'habitude si souriant on se
prenait la tête de bon matin avec
christian jacob
android ce week nyc & chief le 9 avril
non c'est pas lui le débat il a commencé
hier et il va durer on va avoir trois
jours 17 jusqu'au 17
ça fait 8 c'est à dire le vol oui mais
vous c'est le 17 et vous avez noté que
sur le grand axe 4 à circuler mais pas
de bol le seul cas circuler est parti en
pleine interview sur france 2 pas de
temps 2 0 pour prendre le train pour
rentrer pour éviter de rentrer très tard
je suis mis en avant justement pour
avoir un sens j'en ai déjà loupé un
parce qu'elle était avec moi tout est
dit le seul qu'elle ait pas d'accord ça
qu'on adore la tempe et c'est très bien
j'ai eu d'autres trucs j'ai compris je
veux d'autres et je dis tu es et
flippant de ouf
ils ont subi un chocolatier à
chocolatier qui raconte son parcours son
expérience mais peut-être pas du sap été
autant pas de bol
sans foi ni loi
pas mal d'expérience surtout évidemment
soin et tous les matins sur bfm
visiblement a déjà la tête en vacances
de jean jacques bourdin ce matin à 8h30
mois jean pierre pernaut et est en forme
ce midi où il a du mal de mer quand il
parle de voiliers on va maintenant au
bord de la mer avec un bel événement ce
matin dans l'hérault un rassemblement de
voiliers voilier à le tout les a lieu
tous les ans ça s'appelle est ce cas là
c'est parce qu'ils aient tous les jours
j -pp continue de lancer un appel au
vote on avait parlé pour élire le plus
beau marché de france à mon avis on
n'est pas près d'avoir les résultats est
il le plus beau de france à vous le dire
continuez à voter pour le marché de
l'île rouge est en ce moment le site ont
passé à séquence people
j'adore on adore les people plus de
budget on se doit diffuser en direct la
pièce des bus à la pièce pas praticable
victoria chercher mais la pièce que les
filles alors avant le direct il faut un
petit web années pour donner envie ils
sont là en direct tu vois que l'ambiance
dans la troupe il ya une bonne ambiance
c'est bien la troupe de paprika et vu
l'ambiance je comprends mieux pourquoi
jean-mi s'est lancé dans le théâtre
et puis c'est du direct
qu'est ce qu'on fait pour souhaiter
bonne chance merde beaucoup de merde
[Rires]
[Musique]
rémy l'un des coeurs brisés il ya une
candidate qui va dans un salon de
tatouage pour se faire tatouer forcément
mais le tatoueur
regardez bien il est plus concentré sur
ses formes quand elle se retourne et
hyper le sourire quand il se rend compte
que la caméra legouix chance
ça déchire on va revoir ce moment la
palette 3d
regardez ce mouvement de tête là il se
souvient qu'il est filmé il perd le
sourire c'est trop tard grimaud et enfin
ce week-end vous le savez retour de 50
minutes inside s'est amusé à faire un
truc c'est changer les images du
sommaire mais on garde la vraie voix off
et ça marche c'est tout
[Musique]
la story claude françois retour sur les
derniers jours de l'idole de la chanson
disparu tragiquement il ya 40 ans en
exclusivité avec miss france 2010 8
maeva tout nous a invités à partager ses
premières vacances entre 10 et spice
girls
vingt ans après leur séparation le
groupe meetic soit pas forme véritable
retour le coup marketing
et puis la story sharon stone alors que
60 ans un jour me mène adore son
histoire de basic instinct
le film marque à merpins et nord brigil
tous la bienvenue
merci saïdi et non pas du tout et non
c'est bon c'est bon tu vas bien j vous
en voulez encore oui je devrais être
augmenté j'ai voulu regarder à faire
conclut l'émission de sophie davant moi
aussi franchement j'aime beaucoup anne
j'adore sophie davant j'adore l'émission
passe en ce moment j'ai un miroir avant
dans un chez moi je me suis rendu compte
qu'en fait c'est hyper relou vent d'un
miroir parce que chaque fois que tu veux
mais tu en photo pour l'annoncer battait
comme un condensé regardé sur internet
toutes les annonces d'aller voir tous
les gars y'a le gars qui tend à
entraîner rend ici je vais essayer
d'être à côté il ya celui se dit bon bah
va assumer on va poser et à la claquette
sans chausser la ja celui qui en scred
avec la tablette
bien sûr qui passe la main à la porte
mais le meilleur qui se dit je vais
faire l'escalier le pelé bon il est bon
il est donc temps à faire conclut on a
vu un candidat
surprenant voilà je suis heureuse et
j'ai repartir
notre prochain tir lequel 53 ans est
journaliste thierry morocco aussi pu
faire les rênes du shopping avec son
beau manteau rose pastel ans on a
découvert la passion brocante de titi et
c'est vrai que ça donne envie c'est que
la terre depuis qu'il a quitté tpm d'or
mais qu'est ce que vous faites là bas
tous les week-ends géant brocante soit
géré au plus tôt le vendredi matin vers
5 6 heures quand les chats sont pas
encore vendus puis vu qu'on est des
gamins on a bipé juste une lettre dans
ce que dit thierry et ça fait d'autres
matinée un jeu vous cache pas ma force
et ma vraie passion
tous les week-ends je vais au plan d'eau
du matin vers 5 6 heures mon plaisir
d'être avec nous pour les 8 ans enfin
quand même le 19 avril en direct
il sera avec mon bébé moisés petites
choses dont sa blessure mais on adore ça
on sent plus ses all blacks à l'émirat
c'est la maman s'est pas déclaré
l'émissaire à l'essai par j'ai maté jt
tf1 mettant trop tard le micro de gilles
bouleau moi ça me fait toujours rire
donc on l'entend juste dire un truc
qu'une fois que le sujet se lancent à
mon avis il aime bien garance la
nouvelle maquilleuse anne laure cros et
julien cressat d'or
les portes ont du mal à se fermer pas
une personne de plus dans le 12 13 de
france 3 c'est une invitée qui raconte
une anecdote à la journaliste mais vu la
règle de la journaliste marie antoinette
elle s'en bat les camps et les caissons
de cette salle qui est celle pas
exactement identique puisque cette salle
là brûlée mais dans laquelle avait été
jugé marie antoinette belle histoire
c'est fou rien à carrer sur lci a plus
de budget pour faire des reportages
c'est sérieux hein ils ont remplacé le
graphisme par des playmobil
c'est pas une blague regardez c'est à
dire qu'il n'a pas lui même ouvert son
compte à l'étranger lorsqu'il se fait
rattraper par la patrouille
alors on a eu aussi envie de rejouer des
émissions en playmobil jean jacques
bourdin le matin jean luc mélenchon
bonjour vous vouliez dire de quoi on
parle et je ne sais pas c'est très haute
et bien sûr on a fait un version tnt à
deux pas
c'est d'avoir été aussi nombreux mais
c'est bien soirée les nouvelles arrivées
la personne
[Applaudissements]
jean michel mr bercy
il revient au top
[Applaudissements]
camus est ce que tu vas nous faire le
faire du bruit dans un instant ou bien
sûr j'ai pigé des équipes de tpm paie
aujourd'hui au bureau achats d'or noir
caméra dans l'ascenseur on adore ça ce
sera dans un instant dans un instant vos
camions va revenir aussi sur l'affairé y
est boudou la grand-mère de laëtitia on
a des infos on a des images exclusives
voilà dans quel de complément d'enquêté
de ce soir vous allez voir ce qui se
passe et on a la une de public
là aussi c'est paranormal verrait la
hutte de public de derain énorme d'art
car il fera dans un instant c'est
quelqu'un que tu aimes bien bossé énorme
merci tout va bien à toutes ces mesures
piccolo jean vincent placé jean vincent
placé jean vincent placé est en garde à
vue
retrouvez touche pas à mon poste avec
les salons de coiffure fabio salsa fabio
salsa coiffeur experts je ne suis pas
que de blagues de mutation devient la
personne c'est tout le monde attendait
le passage de france brest y aurait ce
qu'il a appelé sa copine florence
foresti revient exceptionnellement sur
ses années télé la télé de foresti
demain à 21h sur ces huit besoin de
volumes pour être au top pour m'asseoir
et sur ses huit facile et rapide avec
mon shampoing sec baptiste retrouver
votre divertissement avec capifrance
vendre acheter louer tout l'immobilier
sur quatre france.fr
[Musique]
l'étude
nouvelle peugeot 308 à partir de 169
euros par mois avec entretien offert
[Musique]
à condé sur vire en normandie la pluie
n'est jamais très loin d'un brin d'herbe
une vache non plus n'est jamais très
loin de cette herbe fraîche sans parler
de l'éleveur qui n'est jamais très loin
de ses vaches ou les gens de la laiterie
ils ne sont pas très loin le manque lui
est là
vous êtes tout près de brega
nouvelle crème légère de la laiterie de
condé sur vire il manquerait mme souza
dit elle et vire l'envi du vrai
[Musique]
moment que je fais
mama c'est toi la plus belle du monde
[Musique]
aucune hôtel à la ronde les plus jolies
pour aménager son jardin tout le monde
fait avec au garden points comme prête
pour 48 heures d'hydratation intense
découvrez le la nourrissant de nivea au
concentré de soin et avec deux fois plus
d'huile d'amande de aussi
[Musique]
c'est parti pour 48 heures de feel good
avec le lait nourrissant 48 heures de
nivea est fondé de plaisir pour la
nouvelle mousse corps de nivea a absorbé
immédiatement essayé la nouvelle mousse
corps de nivea
je cherche quelque chose d'attractif
fessée pour plaire nda noms des clients
d'accord peut-être quelque chose d'un
peu boisée non plus vers ces campagnes
encore plus vert est déjà bien vers
quelque chose qui évoquerait un crédit
flexible avec un taux intéressant
un projet à financer cetelem a des
solutions pour vous et des prêts
personnels crédits renouvelables
regroupe en crédits est en ce moment le
prêt personnel est au taux de 1,7 pour
cent sur 24 mois appelez le 0 800 200
sans rendez vous sur 7 elle aime point
fr cetelem plus responsable ensemble
c'est quoi ça tu avais un whooper dans
la première case de ton ticket king ou
double et tu grattes la deuxième pour te
retrouver avec une petite frite
t'choupi joie puis nous avoir un voyage
moto avec king ou double de burger king
gratter une fois gagné gratter une
deuxième fois pour gagner mieux ou pas
bonjour ouais ce que je te disais à
propos du droit du travail c'est que la
quotité ses cibles c'est la part du
salaire net qui peut faire l'objet d'une
cession ou d'une saisie tuer la bête non
non non non un beau l'utilitaire c'est
comme un bon artisan ça doit savoir tout
faire pendant les jours pro citroën
jumpy et à partir de 149 euros par mois
[Musique]
orientable
rétractable on vit le temps avec les
pergolas bioclimatiques bio saines
oenobiol innove pour dissiper les poches
et les cernes et retrouver un regard
éclatant avec oenobiol poches et cernes
réduisait instantanément en moyenne 60%
des poches en une seule application
oenobiol cosmétiques révéler votre
beauté naturelle le sport vous
connaissez transpirer vous dépasser mais
le sport c'est aussi la joie la joie de
prendre son envol et de retrouver la
terre ferme où la joie d'une virée entre
filles
la joie de se lancer sur un coup de tête
et d'être comme un poisson dans l'eau
la joie de faire le par bravo la joie de
retrouver les copains et de se retrouver
soi-même est tout simplement la joie de
prendre du plaisir
débutants ou sportif accompli nos
conseils et nos produits vous accompagne
chaque jour alors rejoignez-nous est
entré dans la danse
[Musique]
découvrez lors dans ce pack est souple à
sa technologie arm allocs capture tous
les arômes d'un café fraîchement moulu
pour vous faire vivre une expérience
encore plus riche en arômes lors sans
doute le meilleur café du monde avec
elle aux banques
votre carte visa est toujours gratuite
et vous n'avez aucun frais de tenue de
compte
jusqu'à 80 euros offerts et l'eau banque
mobile comme vous
[Musique]
ce tarif
ouais
[Musique]
environnement économie innovation on
n'imagine pas jusqu'où nous permettra
d'aller le recyclage des lampes mais on
sait où ça commence dans un bac de
collecte
déposez vos lampes usagées en
supermarchés et magasins de bricolage
récit l'udm engagé pour un recyclage
responsable
après un cambriolage dans votre quartier
le risque d'être vous même touché
multiplié par trois alors agissez faîtes
confiance à la lame very sûr avec
protection 24 heures sur 24
nos détecteurs de choc repère les
cambriolages avant même l'intrusion
ils permettent à nos agents very sûr
d'agir pour protéger ce qui compte
vraiment votre alarme c'est sûr c'est
very sur pour profiter d'un pack à moins
50%
rendez vous sur very sur point fr
[Musique]
et couvrait villages nature paris la
nouvelle expérience center pas
à trente minutes de paris
[Musique]
retrouvez touche pas à mon poste avec
les salons de coiffure fabio salsa fabio
salsa coiffeur experts evadez-vous de
vente et pmp avec les cafés jacques
vabre issus des terres d'arabica
[Applaudissements]
missions au sein d'un soir on a des
images exclusives de ce qui va compter
ce soir d' enquête étudie comment
d'ailleurs mais nord de plaimont enquête
sur eliette but où la grand-mère de
laëtitia qui a parlé pour la première
fois vous verrez on a plein d'extraits
vous allez réagir là-dessus on à jean
vincent placé deux buts nous sommes
alors alors lui il a complètement pas et
j'ai un portrait robot à vous montrer de
ouf également je pense que vous avez vu
yatir ardisson qui a répondu à la
polémique sur le premier roman simple et
ça chauffe ça chauffe ça chauffe à anja
je vous le dis et je vous le dis on aura
une personne qui va venir nous voir qui
s'appelle anna elle habite dans la
région parisienne et en méditant cette
femme a fait une rencontre elle a
rencontré des extraterrestres
elle pense qu'ils sont partout elle va
tout nous expliquer et on doit jocelyne
kelleher qui sera avec no 6 qui va nous
raconter toutes ces histoires
surnaturelles qui va nous dire ce qui
est vrai ce qui est faux et on aura
également une personne qui a connu la
mort imminente
voilà donc l a vu la mort elle est
vraiment mort venue uniquement va nous
dire ce qu'elle a vu et elle est revenue
voilà un petit peu comme vous
médiatiquement
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
camille combal oui on aime bien quand il
est longtemps
alors quoi tu fais ça vite fait ouais
parce que j'ai pigé une nouvelle fois
les les équipes de tpm paix parce qu'on
a remis une caméra cachée dans
l'ascenseur jeu de la boîte qui est
interdite mekhemar en tout part d'une
vraie info je sais pas si vous savez
c'est vrai de vrai ce que je vous dis à
bientôt il y aura une pénurie de papier
toilette ça a déjà commencé à taïwan
regarder l'info est sérieuse sous la
menace ils en parlent même au gîte
espagne pour vous
laurent blanc est bien ce serait le
papier toilette une pénurie de papier
toilette au sein des rayons à ce sujet
tout à fait sérieux de justin gens comme
ce qui fait croire aux équipes de tp que
cyril aussi lancer l'économie papier
toilette
voici les images de la caméra qu'on a
posés dans l'ascenseur on a collé un mot
disant dans le cadre de la politique
environnementale vérifier s'il vous
plaît d'utiliser seulement cinq feuilles
de papier toilette par jour apporter
votre propre matériel si nécessaire si
la direction
voici les réactions
[Musique]
25 des bad boys dans le cadre de la
politique environnementale voyez s'il
vous plaît vous limiter à 5 étoiles par
jour et par personne
apportez votre matériel nécessaire le
moment jamais arrivé dans l ascenseur
cette jeune fille qu'on ne connaît pas
qui ne bossent pas dans cette société
on ne sait pas ce qu'elle fait là l île
papier elle réagit pas et de quoi se met
à danser sans raison seul avant d'abord
qu'on la baule
je vais aller jean pierre djian torride
elle a donné l'autorisation à passer
sinon ils ont tout donné l'autorisation
la loeb après c'est la boîte à ce que
demain nos malades
merci au qatar
[Applaudissements]